This episode of Real Science is brought
to you by Curiosity Stream. Watch
thousands of documentaries for free for
31 days at curiositystream.com/realscience
It's been all over the news
lately. There have been a record-breaking
number of fires ravaging the Brazilian
Amazon rainforest this year - manmade
fires,
intentionally set to clear land for
agriculture, which then spread
uncontrollably. The National Institute
for Space Research says it has detected
more than 74 thousand fires between
January and August. In comparison there
were fewer than 40,000 for the same
period in 2018. It is shocking to see it
happening to a place many of us consider
to be a pristine lush expanse. And most
of us looking on from thousands of miles
away from behind our computer screens
feel helpless. Members of the G7 summit
pledged 22 million dollars to help fight
the fires. And over the past decade
Norway has donated 1.2 billion dollars
to help conserve the Amazon and Germany
has contributed 68 million dollars.
However they've both stopped their
contributions because of doubts over
Brazil's efforts to reduce deforestation.
Despite money pouring in over many years
to try to battle the problem,
international campaigns, summits, and
boycotts, it just isn't working. The
recent fires are just a symptom of an
ongoing problem of unregulated and
out-of-control clearing for agriculture.
Across the world, in South America, Africa,
and Asia, the world's rainforests are
being lost at a rapid pace. If current
deforestation levels precede, the world's
rainforests may completely vanish in as
little as a hundred years. And there is
so much to lose. The diversity of plants
and animals in the world's rainforests
is staggering,
especially in person. Seeing mist rise
above the canopy at sunrise while
hearing Gibbon calls from miles away,
trekking through the forest at night and
seeing alien like insects,
dodging snakes wrapped around branches,
colorful ridiculous birds. The amount of
amazing creatures there is seemingly
endless.
And the value that they have to the
world is impossible to quantify. And so,
with all the terrible news stories we
hear it's easy to feel like there is no
hope. To see any animals losing their
habitat is heartbreaking. However, despite
the headlines, all hope is not lost. There
are things that can be done and people
who are doing everything in their power
to ensure the rainforests survive the
recent onslaught of destruction. To
understand what is being done and how,
let's focus on one of the most
endangered ecosystems in the world, the
rainforests of Malaysia and Indonesia, and in
particular Borneo - home to recognizable
species such as orangutangs and pygmy
elephant. Borneo's natural forests
continue to be destroyed at a rapid pace.
Between 1985 and 2005 Borneo lost an
average of 850 thousand hectares of
forest every year. If this trend
continues, forest cover will drop to less
than a third in coming years. And all
that deforestation has been devastating
for wildlife. Nearly a hundred and fifty
thousand critically endangered Bornean
orangutans died between 1999 and 2015 and there are less than 1500 surviving
Borneo pygmy elephants. 10 to 15 percent
of the world's unique plant and animal
species live in this area and they are
all at risk of being wiped out entirely.
And this is not to mention the
importance of the forest and its carbon
storing abilities and how devastating
clearing it will be in the battle
against climate change. It's easy to
point out why deforestation is bad for
biodiversity, and no one wants the
orangutans to die, so why is it happening?
The answer to this question varies from
region to region and from year to year.
In Brazil, cattle ranching is the leading
cause. In the DRC it's largely due to
unregulated or illegal logging for
timber. And in Borneo and the rest of
Indonesia and Malaysia, the forests are
currently being cleared to make room for
the most in-demand plant oil in the
world -
palm oil. this huge demand for palm oil
can be traced back to the 1980s when the
world learned the dangers of trans fats.
Food producers scrambled to find a
suitable alternative - something cheap
with similar properties to trans fats
but less damaging to human health. The
substance that ticked these three boxes
was you guessed it, palm oil.
Then in the last few decades
environmentalists ironically pushed for
an increase in biodiesel production to
try to stop the release of carbon from
fossil fuels, not foreseeing the
contradiction in their thinking. In the
US a law mandating that biofuels be
incorporated into diesel promised to stop
the release of 4.5 billion tons of
carbon over three decades. Biodiesel
production in the U.S. jumped from 250
million gallons in 2006 to more than 1.5
billion gallons in 2016. Like many
well-intentioned plans this one did the
exact opposite of what it was supposed
to and helped lead to the ongoing
decimation of one of the world's biggest
carbon sinks. By the 21st century the
palm oil boom was in full swing and
thousands of square miles of lowland
forests across Borneo were planted with
oil palms. Today Indonesia and Malaysia
supply 85% of the world's palm oil, and
whether we realize it or not palm oil is
in everything -
pizza dough, lipstick, ice cream, laundry
detergent, soap, chocolate, instant noodles,
fuel. It's an extremely cheap and
versatile product and it's nearly
impossible to avoid in modern life.
Globally we each consume an average of 8
kilograms of palm oil a year. When you're
in Borneo you can drive for hours and
hours and hours and see nothing but palm
trees. And much of the forest you can see
is under severe pressure with animals
being forced into smaller and smaller
habitats. Trucks carrying the palm
kernels and trucks lugging out massive
ancient trees zigzag across the
landscape. This leads to the hardest
question of it all. What can be done
about it? There's been a recent push to
boycott palm oil products, like the
grocery chain Iceland is doing as
explained in their controversial viral
ad. This kind of stuff feels nice and is
easy for people to support. However,
Europe and the U.S. account for less than
14 percent of global palm oil demand. So
boycotts coming from these parts of the
world are unfortunately not enough. Half
of global demand comes from Asia where
within many of the developing economies
product price is what matters. And with
palm oil accounting for 13.7 percent of
Malaysia's gross national income and
existing as Indonesia's top export,
outright banning its cultivation is just
not going to happen. The way to actually
save the rainforests is unfortunately
way more
complicated. To save the rainforest we
have to understand the rainforest. We
have to understand how it actually
reacts to deforestation and degradation.
Obviously when an entire forest slashed
and burned and logged, that ecosystem is
lost. But what about the surrounding
forests, are they impacted by the
adjacent damage? Are any animals able to
relocate? And if so, what kinds, how many?
What about partially degraded forests, or
young forests that are being restored?
Can they support wildlife? Can some
animals actually even live within the
palm oil plantations? Are wildlife
corridors along rivers enough to promote
the movement of animals across a
plantation landscape? How much forest can we actually lose before the damage is
irreversible? These are the questions
that need to be answered to ensure the
future of the Southeast Asian rainforest,
and in fact any threatened forest in the
world. One group working on finding the
answers to these questions is a group of
scientists nestled deep in the heart of
Malaysian Borneo at the SAFE project
site. SAFE stands for the stability of
altered forest ecosystems and their goal
is to research biodiversity and
ecosystem function change as forests are
modified by human activities and to
learn whether preserving sections of
forests within degraded landscapes can
protect biodiversity, and how much
protection is needed to be effective. The
entire SAFE project experimental site
has an area of 72 square kilometers
which is spread over existing palm oil
plantations and untouched rainforest,
much of which is slated to soon be
converted into palm oil plantations. The
site also contains a large virgin jungle
reserve of 22 square kilometers which
will remain protected throughout the
process. Within the total safe project
area the owners of the palm oil
plantation have agreed to allow an
additional 8 square kilometres of land
to be set aside as forest fragments.
These will be the experimental forest
fragments that the scientists can study.
In addition to this Malaysian law
prohibits the clearance of forests on
steep slopes and along rivers accounting
for another approximately five square
kilometres. With this arrangement the
scientists will be able to study the
effect of logging before during and
after such forest conversion and can
also study the effects of forest
corridors and reserves within damaged
forests. This type of experimental design
is extremely valuable and
extremely rare. It is not often that
scientists get to work with the
cooperation of the very people who are
doing the damage that is being studied
and get to choose where their
experimental sites are. In most cases
ecological research is carried out
observationally, after the fact, which
does not produce as powerful of results
as an experiment like this will. The
overall goal of the safe project is to
determine the minimum critical size
forest fragments can be before they fail
to operate as functional tropical
ecosystems. They are gathering data on
animal populations, soil composition,
plant populations, hydrology, insect
behavior, seed dispersal, everything that
a healthy tropical ecosystem needs and
seeing how that changes in different
levels of forest destruction. And with
this information the ultimate goal is to
find out the best way to sustainably
farm palm oil - to find a compromise
between agriculture and conservation. And
while this experiment is set to go on
for many years to come and the full
results won't be known until then, there
are already hundreds of papers pouring
out of this research site and some of
the results already have big
implications. One study for example found
that riparian reserves, the strips of
forests that are protected along the
lengths of rivers, that have over 40
metres of natural vegetation on each
bank supported similar bird diversity to
the control habitats found in continuous
protected forests. However to support
equivalent numbers of birds of
conservation concern, reserves would need
to be at least a hundred metres wide on
each bank. Another study concluded that
over all mammal species richness was
conserved even in degraded forests,
forests that otherwise might be thought
to be too damaged already to be worth
protecting. And yet another study found
unexpectedly that there is no impact
from land use changes on the biomass or
number of fish and small streams,
suggesting that these fish could be a
sustainable food source for villages
established in human modified forests or
in developed oil palm plantations. These
are the types of results that SAFE wants
to use to inform how palm oil is farmed
and in fact how any fragmented landscape
can be designed to best preserve the
environment in the face of land-use
change. And once even more years of data
have been collected the SAFE project
will inform relevant governments about
the best land-use policy. For example, at
the moment
governmental guidelines on the amount of
riparian reserves around rivers varies
greatly. In Sabah, the law says that 20
meters of natural vegetation on either
side of a riverbank has to be preserved.
In Indonesia it's 50 meters, in other
parts of Malaysia it's 5 meters, and
other regions have different guidelines
altogether. But as I mentioned before
some studies are already finding that
maybe a hundred meters or more are
necessary to be sufficient wildlife
corridors to preserve biodiversity.
Results like these will be funneled to
policymakers and members of the round
table for sustainable palm oil to try to
set up a system in which despite some
deforestation happening now, the
rainforest can survive and rebound once
the local economies move on to other
forms ofiIndustry one day in the future.
To really save the rainforest requires
an unromantic often tedious compromise
between industry, ecology, and politics.
None of it is easy, and with fairly
rampant corruption in many of the
countries in question, undermining any
progress made, it can feel like an
impossible battle. It will take years of
discussion from the decision-makers, long
hours spent in the field, and integrity
from relevant politicians. But with all
of these things working together, in
theory, there is hope for a future world
still covered in rainforests. The subject
of deforestation is a massive one and
there are many many things we need to
understand in order to save the world's
forests. Scientists everywhere are
tirelessly gathering data and
discovering the answers needed to inform
conservation efforts. And while they are
working to understand the rainforest, we
can work to understand their efforts and
the ecology that surrounds the problem
by signing up to Curiosity Stream.
Curiosity Stream has thousands of high
quality documentaries including many
about environmental and ecological
subjects. You can learn more about the
fascinating work being done to study the
impact of forest fires in the Amazon for
example in the documentary called Amazon
Burning. It highlights the complex field
work being done there and explains some
of the high-tech methods used for
measuring carbon storage in tropical
ecosystems. And because Curiosity Stream
also loves independent creators,
an annual subscription to Curiosity
Stream now includes a subscription to
Nebula - a streaming site created by a
bunch of the best educational YouTube
content creators like Tierzoo,
Minutephysics, Wendover Productions, and
our other channel Real Engineering.
Nebula is a place for videos to be
watched ad free and for creators to try
new ideas without fear of demonetization
on YouTube.
The next Real Science video is already
available on Nebula, which won't be on
YouTube for another month. It's also
building its library with loads of
exclusive content like Real Engineering's
Logistics of D-Day series coming out
at the end of this month. So to get all
that along with access to Curiosity
Stream's library, sign up at curiositystream.com/realscience and
you'll get an email with a link to get
your free Nebula subscription. Learning
about a wide range of subjects like the
one on Curiosity Stream and Nebula is
one of the best things you can do to
help the world in its environmental
battles.
you